(audience cheering)
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys.
- [Woman] We love you!
- I love you back.
(audience laughter)
How many people
here have seen one of my
full keynotes on
YouTube, raise your hand.
Right, so as you can imagine,
I'm sure there's
people in this room that
don't know who I am, and I'll
give you a little context.
I feel like I'm a
CAT scan of business.
It's really interesting
to me, much like many of you
can do certain
things very quickly like,
I would equate it to
if you're a great cook,
you can open a refrigerator,
look at it, scan it,
find things and then
cook and create a meal.
I couldn't do that on
my best day, you know.
But I can absolutely hear a
question about a business,
reverse engineer it
and start figuring out
how to make it more
profitable or more successful.
That's what's been
in me my whole life,
and that's why I really
do want to get into Q&amp;A.
Regardless of what
you're trying to sell,
or if you're trying to
raise money for a non-profit
or help a family
that's house burnt down
or whatever you aspire to do
from my biggest clients
like Toyota and
Chase and Budweiser,
to somebody who yesterday
decided they're gonna try
an entrepreneurial
venture and they want people
following them for
their fitness advice,
the one thing we all
trade on here is attention.
It's why this has
become the big mantra for me.
I day trade attention
and build businesses.
The reason I put day
trade is I've come to realize
how unbelievably fast the world
I care about is in actuality.
Let me explain in
a very finite detail.
If I stood here
nine months ago today,
I would go on a rant
about Snapchat and Facebook
and tell you
somewhere during that rant
that I was
concerned about Instagram,
because I felt that
practitioners didn't realize
how young Facebook
was, and by the way
I'll say it again here,
if you're trying to sell
to 25, 26, 27-year-olds
in the world,
including Instagram,
there is still no
place like Facebook because
of its ad product, so
that's much younger than people
think, and then
Snapchat nine months ago today,
was much older
than people thought.
I was watching and
seeing the conversions
of 30, 35-year-olds at
scale and growing by the day.
Every single day,
hundreds of thousands of
35 to 40-year-olds
getting on the platform.
So nine months ago today,
I would've stood here
and said Instagram's in trouble.
It's getting
squeezed from both ends.
I stand here
today to tell you that
there's no
platform more important.
So your feelings felt
better that you got more views
on the stories on Instagram
than you did on Snapchat,
so you jumped off of
Snapchat and thought you only
needed one, and what that
meant was the trade on
attention shifted,
and the deal became
even more extreme on Instagram.
So the thing that
I'm always scared of
is how many people in
the room will read a book
or a blog post or
even watch one of my videos
from three months ago,
from six months ago,
and then from two years ago,
and four years ago.
The thesis,
the clouds as I call them,
always gonna be the same.
The dirt, the details,
I promise you,
the single biggest
reason that I have the luxury
of standing up here,
and many of you don't,
is that I'm a much better
practitioner than you are.
People like to talk
in thesis, and to me
that is the punchline.
That is why I love
Q&amp;A 'cause I'll give you
the actual answer in detail.
It's about the practitionership.
You know I've never
really gone down this path.
DRock's gonna be excited
'cause I'm gonna go
to a different place right now.
I keep the GaryVee thing
that the majority of people
are here for, not only because
it makes my ego
feel good, and it does.
(audience laughter)
I keep it because
it forces me to be
the best
practitioner in the craft.
I continue to build my
brand more than any other
reason, and there's a lot of
vanity that comes with it,
there's a lot of financial
aspects that come along with it,
but I want
everybody to know, and again,
my behavior has proven this,
because I did it
before this happened.
The single
biggest reason I continue
to build my personal
brand, is it forces me
every single day, to
use Instagram, Snapchat,
Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube, Tumblr.
It forces me, and
then I become the plumber
not just the architect.
And there's way too
many architect's in here,
and there's way too
many plumbers in here,
and there's not enough
of people that are both.
And all the action,
all the upside, all the growth
in building big businesses comes
from being able to do both.
Stop reading books,
stop watching documentaries,
stop hiring more services,
coaches, people,
all which are disguises for you
not to actually do the work.
(audience cheers)
I'm curious when
that's gonna happen,
because that has
been fascinating to me.
I think the thing
that I am most proud of,
and that I spend
a ton of time on,
and you guys
have heard it from me,
and I don't know if
you think I'm doing it
'cause I think it's funny,
I love when
people stop watching me.
I like when people
hit me up and go GaryVee,
now I'm not
watching you any more.
And then I go to
their Instagram account
three weeks later,
'cause you guys know I'm weird,
I do that kinda stuff, and then
they're just
watching somebody else.
I'm like no, no no,
you missed the point.
The point is doing
is the only option.
Doing is the only option.
It's the only way to win.
Work ethic is the
main thing that everybody
in this room controls.
You're not gonna
control your talent.
control your charisma.
You're not gonna control your
looks, you're really not,
I mean, the fact of
the matter is, you can make
all those things a
little bit better, but you're
gonna only max them out.
It's the work ethic,
A, that makes them all
a little bit better.
It is the most controllable
aspect of your life,
and your career, and
it's the thing that most
people don't wanna do.
As a lot of you know, who've
been following me a long time,
three years ago I decided
to take care of my health,
and I've gotten those benefits.
Like it wasn't easy,
I didn't want to do it,
I didn't do it for 35 years
of my life, I came up with
every excuse of why.
I'm busier than I've
ever been, and I do it more
than I've ever done before.
So the excuses are the
excuses, and we all have them
in different parts of our lives.
The fact of the matter is,
building a meaningful business,
something that you can
live your life on, no matter
what your means are.
Even call it $100,000 of
profit in a year
to allow you to live a really
great life if, you know,
if you don't let
yourself dream of
like trillions of dollars.
Even that is difficult,
'cause if it wasn't,
the math would
play out differently.
There's a reason that the
math of, the top one percent
of earners in the entire
country, and take in all the
billionaires and, you're
talking about $400,000 a year.
That's a lot of money,
yet, nobody even starts
a conversation of success
lower than a million dollars.
Yet 400,000, data,
math, 400,000 is the bottom
of the top one percent
of earners in this country.
You know, even if we just
change the conversation to,
I want to make
$400,000 a year, it would change
your behavior because so
many people in their goals
to achieve these great big
businesses, become impatient,
are looking for shortcuts,
and want it to happen quickly,
which means, and I know this,
which means you just start
doing stuff that you
don't feel good about.
Whatever the hell you're up
to, if I can have you leave
with anything, here are
basically the core pillars,
before I get into Q&amp;A.
So you have a mic right?
Who's got mics?
How many do we, do we
have any of those, great.
So before I get into
Q&amp;A and I'm going in earlier
than I expected
based on how many hands.
The core pillars are, if
you're not trading attention,
if you are not putting
out content where people
actually are, you lose.
You're basically quiet.
Like if you are not
successful at putting out
written words, pictures,
videos, or audio, four things.
If you are not capable for
what you're trying to achieve
and why you're here today,
to write something, to put
a picture that shows
something, to audio it
in podcast form, or
some other form, or a video
on the seven to 10 platforms
that live on this device,
you are 100%
irrelevant in 2017.
That is, that is
something you have to
wrap your head around.
If you are not communicating,
and by the way,
not as a personal brand, right?
Like you can be Toyota,
you can be an energy drink,
you can be a sneaker,
or you can be you,
but if that, those,
either one of those two things
is not producing one
of those four core things,
in one of these 10
websites, Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram, Snapchat,
you know LinkedIn, you know
podcast form,
Medium, or a blog form.
If you're not doing that,
you're silent to the world,
because I don't know
where you think the attention
of the consumer actually is.
Everybody in this room
for free, has bigger audience
on 10 websites, or apps
on this device, and they
don't realize it, and
what they get hurt by,
is the supply and demand issue.
The problem is, as
great as what I just said is,
that you have bigger reach
capability than
those characters,
the problem is
everybody in this room has
that same reach capability.
Everybody in this state,
everybody in this country,
so now you get
into supply and demand.
I love, I can't wait for
one of you to ask, hey Gary,
but I produce great content,
but nobody's listening.
That's my favorite,
Gary, I'm making great stuff
and everybody's
following all these crapheads.
My stuff is great,
why's it not working?
'Cause your stuff is crap.
(audience laughter)
You think it's great,
your momma said it was great,
but the market didn't.
- [Man] Amen.
- Amen is right my friend.
The market, is the
market, is the market.
It's always right.
You don't like that
people watch the Kardashians?
Tough shit.
(audience laughter)
The market spoke, right?
You don't like that I watch
grown men run into each other
for four hours a day on
Sundays in the Fall and Winter?
Tough, the market spoke, right?
You can't decide, what is
really imperative in this room
is to figure out
how you bring value
in today's modern world.
What products and
services can you deploy,
and where is the attention?
What are you actually offering?
Are you commoditized?
And really to be very frank
given the makeup of the room,
do you actually even give
a crap about your customer,
in what you're trying
to achieve, or is it just
solely about what
you're trying to achieve?
When I really
audited some of the people
that were coming to
this event using this hashtag
yesterday, and I looked at what
they do and how they do it,
you don't give a rat's
ass about anybody but what
you're trying to achieve
and sell, and it's so quick
and easy for me to taste it,
it took me about five seconds.
So that's something
you need to think about,
because the second you
deploy selfish behavior is the
second that you're
losing other people's attention.
I understand that you
want stuff to be automated,
and hit one button, and send
an email to 100,000 people,
and lots of people buy.
I understand that's
why it's good for you.
I also understand that
when that's happening to you,
you delete that email before
you even start reading it.
I understand that you
want to make a Facebook ad
that sells your thing,
that you want them to watch
the two minute video and
buy your thing, but I also
know that every time you see
that in your Facebook stream,
you do this.
Let me tell you the quickest
way to become very successful
at selling something,
to become very
empathetic very quickly.
Empathy my friends, is
the secret drug of sales.
I always, always, only care
about what you're thinking.
You know why you guys like me?
'Cause I'm empathetic.
'Cause I'm bringing
you way more value than
I'm asking for you in return.
You guys know why you like me?
'Cause I look different than
people that look like me,
'cause I'm not
asking, I'm giving.
And so when I say to you,
don't listen to what I'm saying,
watch what I'm doing,
that's what I mean in a macro,
and then the micro, there's
a reason I put 15 hashtags
on every post on Instagram.
There's a reason I ask
you to swipe up and draw
on top of an Instagram story.
There's a reason I have
call to actions at the
end of a YouTube video.
There's a reason I reply to so
many of you in the comments.
Watch those things.
I can say anything I want,
my behavior trumps it all.
If you don't see
me going hardcore on
Snapchat glasses or VR,
that means I don't believe in it
at this second,
but I'm watching it, right?
I'm doing nothing.
Let me promise you one thing,
I'm doing nothing by accident.
There's nothing I do
for kicks and giggles.
It's all strategic, it's
all for me to collect data,
it's all for me
to make decisions on.
So, what I'm asking you to
do, is pay closer attention
to what I'm doing, and
replicate that behavior
for your audience,
because you know it works,
'cause it's working on you.
The problem is, nobody
wants to put in the work
and the
patience that that takes.
I understand why you
don't want to do it, it sucks.
Yet me, who works 18 hours
a day and I've proven
that to you over the last year
and a half with DailyVee.
Me, who works 18 hours a
day, who travels 500 times
a year, who does all
that stuff, is engaging with
his community more than every
single person in this room.
You're so fancy you
don't have time to reply to the
three people that left you a
comment on your Instagram post?
(audience laughter)
I mean, seriously.
Everybody loves to talk
about loving their community
and you care
about your customer.
Really?
Because the 12 people
I audited last night, by the way
at midnight in my
hotel room before this talk
so I could bring you value,
when I looked at you,
and I looked at your stuff,
you're really good at
throwing your right hooks
and getting your people
into your products and
services, but you actually
replied to zero
people collectively,
in the comments of those posts.
Because you
actually don't give a shit,
and smart winners can smell it.
And I promise you, let me give
you a really bad business;
selling to losers.
(light audience laughter)
Thank you.
(audience cheers and applause)
First name and where you're
from, and then we'll roll.
- Jared Greenhurst
from Salt Lake City, Utah.
- Awesome.
- Welcome to Utah man.
- Thank you my man.
- Low riders...
- (laughs) Yeah what's up?
- My question is
so I built a business from
zero to five million
in the last two years.
- Amazing.
- And dealing with the
next piece, and I know you are
a dictator on culture,--
- Yes
- like your Honey Empire game.
How many people are you
actually managing and how do you
scale that, even from
now from 700 to like 3,000,
'cause you, I know
you're dealing with that,
how do you have that,
all the way down to 701?
- You don't, what
you do is you make,
in my company of 750,
I try to make 650 people know
that my door is open,
and it is, so when number 419
emails Tyler that five
minutes is being scheduled
within three to six weeks.
My father-in-law Peter Kline
has a friend here,
and different like, whether
you've worked in big companies,
or you've got a small company,
the quickest, biggest mistake
that people make is they
don't have the 20 to 30 people
that directly
impact their business.
The top, let's just
call it the top one percent,
don't even call it 20 or 30.
If your right-hand
person isn't 100% aligned
with you on everything,
you are vulnerable.
I fire the inner 20,
top 20 or 30, pretty often
if they waver from me,
because I'm vulnerable
to them not executing my vision.
So how many
people do you have?
- [Jared] We've got 25.
- Right, 25.
So, those top five or seven,
number four, she might
be so important to you.
She may do the thing
that you don't know how to do,
or don't like to do,
which is always important.
A CFO, I don't want to
do the finances, right?
I just did an episode
with my CFO, if you saw it.
I don't like to do that,
I'm not a CFO-driven guy.
I don't make my
money by cutting costs.
I make my money by selling,
that has always been my career.
I don't like to do that
but I've always had the person,
the person has to be in place.
My last CFO, some of you
who have been
following me for a while,
we used to call
him CFbrO, right?
Scott Heydt, I love him, right.
He's in the Namely
commercials right now.
I haven't stopped those
'cause I have love for him.
But it got to a point
where he wasn't
executing how I needed,
and he couldn't
be there anymore.
Undermining certain
things that you believe in,
she's gotta go.
And most people
don't make that move.
They value the
money over the culture.
money over the thesis.
They value the short term
money over the long term money.
And then by the way,
you just put in the work.
You can't read
about doing push-ups.
So, you just have
to allocate the time.
And the other thing is
you need to face the things
that you don't wanna face.
Like I know my shortcomings.
I don't like them, but every
time I'm with my direct people,
my leaders,
I expose myself to them,
so that they know I know them.
Because that builds trust.
Got it?
- [Jared] I got it, thank you.
- That's it,
it's the only way.
Yep, hey, man.
- [Sergei] Hi,
Gary, my name's Sergei,
and I'm a big fan of you.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Sergei] I'm from Russia, man.
- I love it, I know it well.
- [Sergei] My question is:
what are the biggest mistakes
you see young entrepreneurs make
when starting their own
company or, you know, app,
and stuff like that.
- To generalize, Sergei,
the biggest mistakes are
number one, especially in the
tech world we live in now,
they're not
actually building businesses.
They wanna raise money,
like, let me
just remind everybody.
How many people here have
raised money for their business?
Raise your hands. Right.
Big thing for you guys.
It doesn't take a hero
to lose money each month.
(audience laughter)
Everybody can do that.
So, the biggest thing,
Sergei, is I have a lot of,
and I'm involved in a
lot of these business,
they raise money,
they're losing money each month.
They're not
actually building a business,
they're building a
financial arbitrage machine.
They're trying to hit metrics
to get to the
next round of funding.
Huge mistake, especially if the
macroeconomic climate
collapses, which 8, 9 years in,
and you guys have been
hearing it from me, right.
I brought Tony Robbins
on the show
to talk about
Wall Street and that,
more so than the
thing that you would think
that me and him
would talk about.
Because I wanna
get this in your mind,
it can't last forever.
That's number one.
Number two, kids are impatient.
Everybody's impatient,
kids are triple impatient.
Because you're in
that part of your life
where you wanna
prove everybody wrong.
Right? You're in that place
where you're gonna show Dad
that you're
right and he's wrong.
You're gonna show your
friends that you're special.
There's that
video from the other day
that I put as a
separate piece of content today,
that call I had,
how many people
saw the #AskGaryVee
where I talked to
Taylor for like 20 minutes?
Raise your hands.
The reactions on
this video are so insane.
I'm sure you watched it.
That's what
young entrepreneurs are
making a mistake of.
She's got
nothing going on at 22,
and she's telling me she's
gonna be a millionaire at 25.
How?
You guys make up dumb shit.
(audience laughter)
So, impatience and
lack of actually building
a profitable business.
Lack of practicality,
lack of experience.
You've heard me say,
many of you have heard me say,
I built my dad's
business from 3 to 60 million,
it should have been 200 million
because I figured out
AdWords before anybody else
but I didn't put all
my money into AdWords
because I was doing
direct mail, and radio,
and television because
I didn't have the experience
to know that when
you've got the best hand,
you put all your money on it.
I thought I had
to do everything.
Now that I know that at 41,
I am putting all my money
into Facebook, and
Instagram, and Tumbler
because that's the best
hand, and I'll milk that.
And when it changes, I'll adjust
but I'm not gonna hedge,
which why I've been so loud.
- [Man 2] A big buzz
word right now is passion.
- [Gary] Passion.
- [Man 2] Find your passion.
You might be
sitting at a desk job
but you need to
find your passion.
When I look at my
career, your career,
the way it's actually
presented, you have one passion.
What I'm thinking is,
I saw your passion with wine.
- Yes.
- [Man 2] And I see your passion
with VaynerMedia, your brand.
Is it possible that we
have more than one passion?
- [Gary] Of course.
- [Man 2] It comes
down to something inside of us.
- [Gary] I also think, my man,
that you have to ladder it up.
My passion is to
communicate complicated things
in average-Joe talk.
That's why I won in wine,
wine's complicated, right?
How many people know somebody
that's really into wine?
Raise your hands.
Great, so 80% of you
know that once somebody
learns a lot of about wine,
they become a
straight douchebag.
(audience laughter)
Right?
Like that's what happens.
So, me being Jersey and being
into wrestling and sports,
I'm like, you know what,
I know the most about wine.
The most, I know
as much as the top
10,000 people about
wine, or in that mix.
Let me talk to people about wine
the way we talk
about everything else.
Let's not put
wine on a pedestal.
Now, what I do really
well, for whatever reason,
I have figured
somewhere around that time
when I started Wine Library TV,
the way I communicate,
and I truly believe
what I'm about to say,
because I don't think
I was very well educated
and I've always
lived in my own bubble,
I think I say the same stuff
that has always been said.
I just think I say
it a different way
because I don't
know the other way
that it's actually said
like everybody else says it.
And I think that,
for some reason,
that helps people because
it's just a different way.
And I also
think that people feel
that I actually mean it.
So, I think that
has a lot to do with it.
My passion is to
communicate the things
I most believe in.
Whether that's the
good values in wine
or the business
opportunities of the day.
But, yes, of course,
we're passionate a bunch of,
I mean, I could
start a Jets show,
I could start a root beer
show when I'm off my diet.
I could talk
about a lot of stuff
that I'm passionate about.
I don't think you need to be
crippled to your one passion.
And we evolve.
What you're
passionate about at 24
is different than what
you're passionate about at 33.
And it's different what
you're passionate about at 57.
Plus life brings things.
I promise you, if
one of the four or five
most important people in my life
pass away from a rare disease,
I'm gonna be passionate about
figuring out that disease.
- [Man 3] I'm trying to decide
should I just grow
it and do my own product
and just shout out my own stuff
or go the influencer
route? And when do I determine
to monetize or just keep growing
just giving free content?
- I think this is what's great
about Q&amp;A, hold the mic.
Can you afford to
continue to not monetize?
- [Man 3] I could.
- Because?
- [Man 3] Because I go to school
and I, I'm just.
- You don't need a lot of money.
- [Man 3] I don't.
- You keep it...
- [Man 3] (mumbles)
- Humble.
I think you hold your
breath as long as possible
because you build more equity.
The second you go in for the ask
is the second that
you're giving away the leverage.
When you're giving,
you're gaining leverage.
That's why I have so
much leverage with you.
When I'm giving, I build,
build, build up leverage.
I hate when I come out with a
book every two or three years
and I'm like, can
you guys buy books?
I'm like, I hate it,
I have a goal.
I have to do something
but I hate that month or two
and then people are like,
"GaryVee, you've changed."
I'm like shit, this shit again?
You know like...
(audience laughter)
I hate that month!
The biggest problem, my man,
that a lot of people here
that are not kids make is
when they start getting into
a little bit of money, they
start spending it on dumb shit.
Which then forces
them to have to make more,
which means then they
get into short-term behavior
and they
continue to take leverage
and give it to the other person.
Which makes them a
sleazy sales person
one way or the other
over time, and then they lose.
I would say wait
as long as possible.
If you were 34 years old and
lived with four roommates
in the basement
of somebody's home
in the suburbs
of Salt Lake City,
I'd be pumped with
you because that means
you're holding your breath.
Dude, I was 29 years old
and lived in a $2,000 a month
rent apartment in
New Jersey which, by the way,
Jersey rents are
different than here, right?
Had nothing.
I had a car, a Jeep Cherokee,
and had built a
business from three,
at that point to
40 million in revenue
and was paying
myself $49,000 a year.
I don't give you
advice that I didn't take.
All these
23-year-olds on Instagram
who want to buy
watches and go on private jets.
When I make fun of that,
it's not 'cause I'm jealous.
It's not because I want
to rag on somebody or compete
'cause it's fucking stupid.
(audience laughter and applause)
Do you understand what
you could do with that $5,000?
You could reinvest
it into your business.
The reason
Wine Library grew so fast,
why do you think
VaynerMedia's growing so fast?
Everyone's like, why is
VaynerMedia growing so fast?
It's 'cause I reinvested
in the business.
It's 'cause I put the
money into the business.
Everybody wants
to build a business.
You know many people
here want to build a business
or a personal brand so
they can buy stuff with it?
That thing I said the
other day on the vlog, right,
I don't want to buy a
private jet like everybody
tells me to do
when they see that
I'm wasting an hour on
an extra commercial flight
because I want to
buy the New York Jets.
You know what I mean?
(audience applause)
All this behavior, my man,
is predicated on insecurity.
You know why
24-year-old dudes buy watches?
'Cause they're not
confident and they need that
to get a girl.
(audience laughter)
All those dudes that are
flashing on social media,
I look at them like, insecure.
Not real confident.
You know, puffed up fake.
You know it's
the same old thing.
It's the same reason people
buy followers on social--
Guys, and some of you did
it 'cause one of the people
I looked at last
night that's here
with the hashtag bought it.
You know how I know?
You can't have
800,000 followers on Instagram
and get 27
comments and 94 likes.
(audience laughter and applause)
I ended my talk with it,
which is the worst businesses
to sell to losers
and I promise you
there's a stunning
amount of people here
who try to sell to
the bottom-feeders.
And you never trick winners.
When people DM me,
and they're like,
"Yo GaryVee,
check me out, I'm killing it."
They've got 900,000
followers on Instagram,
but they don't actually have it.
I reply, "No, you aren't."
Then their feelings are hurt.
(audience laughter)
And it makes me feel awesome.
Hold your breath.
Keep building for the audience.
Bring them value.
You know what you're
next Instagram post should be
instead of taking
$400 for a sponsored ad?
Why don't you're
next Instagram post be,
"What can I do for you guys
to make this account better?"
Then read all the
comments and then act on them.
- [Man 4] What
peaks your interest
on one, if it's going to work?
And two, if you want to invest
your time and money in it?
- [Gary] How many users it has.
You've heard me say this,
if you've been
following my stuff,
I'm not Nostradamus.
I'm not
predicting the next apps.
I'm just watching the ones
that are already popping.
The only thing
that peaks my interest
is reverse engineering
the actual market.
Again, I don't to
say if all of a sudden,
let's talk about
what peaked my interest
in Snapchat five years ago.
Users.
It was ranked 130
in the top 150 apps
in the world in the App Store.
That caught my attention,
so I downloaded it.
And then I said,
"This thing's confusing."
Right?
Then it was 111, then
it was 96, then it was 74,
then it was in the
40's for a long, long time
and that peaked my interest.
I don't judge if
Twitter is smart or stupid.
Snapchat is smart or stupid.
I don't judge if
Musical.ly is smart or stupid.
I judge that
people are using it.
And then I try
to figure out why.
And I try to figure out
how to story tell on it,
contextual to the platform
with the content that
is most important to me.
The end.
You just have to
be the tallest midget.
(audience laughter and applause)
You know?
- Hey, my name's Taylor.
I'm from Wayhigh, Utah.
I'm a big fan.
- [Gary] Hey, Taylor. Thank you.
- So I have a question,
Have a great family,
great friends,
great surroundings,
but I feel like in the culture
that I was raised in,
I had a lot of limited beliefs.
- [Gary] About upside
of like, yeah.
- Exactly.
- [Gary] Like keep it
humble, chill, okay.
- So how does someone
overcome limited beliefs
that are imposed on us
by school teachers
growing up, surrounding.
- Family, uncles, yeah.
- [Taylor] Exactly.
- By not giving a
shit about what they think.
- [Taylor] I don't
give a shit but--
- You do though
because you asked the question.
(audience laughter)
You know what I mean?
You say you don't but you do.
And by the way we all do.
But that's the answer.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- You have to understand,
I've lived this.
Literally, somewhere in my
early teens and late teens,
just started looking
at my teachers and parents
and just saying, "Sorry.
"You're just not going to be
able to impose your will on me.
"This is what's up."
I did that at a
very, very young age.
There's plenty of
60-year-olds, right now,
whose 82-year-old mother
is still suppressing them.
I'm not saying
I'm, I'm just thankful.
I don't think I'm cool.
Please know that
I'm not saying that
because I think I'm cool.
I think I was lucky
by given the chemicals
that I was given DNA-wise
to have the audacity to do that.
I don't know
where that came from.
It's not like I read a book
or trained
myself as a 15-year-old
to be like, "Okay, I'm not going
to care what anybody thinks."
That's not, that's insane.
The other thing is,
what's interesting, and
you've heard this from me,
I'm also pushing
from the other direction.
I genuinely don't give a crap
about what anybody thinks
and I equally think I care
about what you all think.
Which is what makes
me the guy that I am.
I'm pulling from opposite sides.
But the thing that
you're worried about,
very simply, this is a cliche,
and I would say
this is 98% likely,
is you're worried
about talking a big game
and then failing and
then them all saying,
"I told you so. You
should have kept it humble."
To me, that's the insight.
- [Taylor] So--
- Keep going.
- [Taylor] I own a business.
- Yep.
- [Taylor] I painted
all my vehicles hot pink
so I don't care what
people think on that.
So mine's more
of scale and size.
I feel like a lot of
people don't have confidence
in getting from five
million to 10 million,
or turning it into 20 million.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So more along those lines.
- [Gary] You're looking
for that confidence?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I think the other thing
to give real thought to,
and this is a tough one,
is a lot of time, people
aren't spending their time
with other winners, right?
I think that, and the way
that you asked the
question the first time,
I was going to go
here and then I pivoted
based on what you said,
you might have to move. Right?
Or you might have to
start spending a lot of,
so one of the great things,
let's say you
don't want to move.
But you've got this business.
What I would tell you,
back to the same
advice that I gave
to that young man, right there.
I would give up all
your profits to travel,
a ton every year.
And go to places where people
are bigger winners than you.
It feels like you just need
to be rubbed off
on with other winners.
I definitely changed,
and I was already a "winner,"
when I started spending time
with Mark Zuckerburg, and
Travis, and the people who
were going to go on
to change the world.
The ambition of the
conversation changed.
They were on a
kick to build products
that were going to change
every single person's lives,
and they did.
Go Google this.
Go put Gary Vaynerchuk,
Uber, Business Insider.
They wrote the article.
I was in the room.
In the room.
Back to a Hamilton reference,
I was in the room when
Garrett Camp invented Uber.
Literally, verbatim,
seven people
sitting in a room
in Paris, him saying,
"What if you could order a limo
"with your iPhone?"
And we were like,
"That's just for rich people."
(audience laughter)
It sounds like you
need to spend more time
with people that
will press you up
instead of push you down.
(audience applause)
And there's a way to do that
without moving to New York City.
It's going to these conferences.
And I don't mean to be,
and this is with all respect,
more coaching, more
motivational me stuff.
I mean, go to an
Elon Musk conference.
Go to an Apple conference.
Stuff that's less about
the emotional part of it
and more about the
black and white part of it.
I mean,
I've been offered, you know,
$500,000 to wear
a pair of sneakers.
Stuff that is life
changing, game changing,
super fun to brag
about, and just weird.
I haven't gone
there because that's not
how I want to monetize.
But, you'll be
pumped about this,
you can get
everybody by just asking.
It's literally just asking.
You don't know what's going
to drive Mark Cuban, or
Tim Ferriss, or Beyonce.
But it's something.
- [Man 5] You know,
it's funny you say that
because I've heard you talk
about a lot of
people emailing you
asking for $10,000
to start a business
and I just published this book
called Business Funding Formula.
And I can do an
Amazon free download
for all those
people that need to learn
how to get money
for their business.
Maybe some zero
percent line credit,
that kind of thing.
- Was that a right hook?
(audience laughter)
- [Man 5] No, it was my value
to let it be free.
- Yeah, that's not
real value, brother.
That's you pitching your shit
in disguise as value.
I'm being serious.
- [Man 5] I believe you.
(audience cheers and applause)
- That's cool though.
By the way, I'm a salesman.
It doesn't bother me
but I want you to win.
20,000 of
200,000 is very different
from 200,000 to
two million a month
or 20 million a month, right?
So the big difference between
20,000 and 200,000 a month
and two million and 20 million
is understanding
that wasn't actual value.
That's disguised value
that's in your best interest.
It's like a humble brag.
Like, I'm working so hard,
I'm making 10 trillion a year.
That's not, you
know, that's like.
(audience laughter)
- [Man 5] What's
an example, though?
- An example is having nothing
that values you when
you gift to somebody.
Like you promoting
your zero-priced book now
in front of everybody,
that's value to you.
So it's the mindset of
not thinking about yourself.
It's a mind shift.
And just knowing
that you have the skills
that it'll come
to you regardless.
It's a good feeling.
And it's really interesting.
So I think, people are like,
"Get my free ebook.
It's value to you."
No it's not.
It's a gateway drug for you
to sell them something else.
The fuck's the matter with you?
(audience laughter and applause)
Right?
So it's like that mentality.
You know what I mean?
Cool.
- My question is,
if you were writing a book
and you were self-publishing,
how would you distribute it
and what would
your marketing be like?
- You would do
it through Amazon,
not super hard.
It's nice that self-publishing
doesn't have as much stigma
as it did five or 10 years ago.
I mean, five or 10
years ago, at a conference,
someone saying
"self-publishing,"
you're like,
"Oh, spam, crap," right?
It's now slightly
gotten to a better place
which I think is great.
I would use
influencers and Facebook ads.
I mean, my stuff is
super easy to understand.
All I care about is under,
when I say "day trade
attention," everything works.
You could run a
television commercial
during the Super Bowl,
I just don't
think you can afford it.
So you have to find the things
that are underpriced.
The underpriced
attention right now
are Facebook ads and
you can target people
based on what
your subject matter
of your book is
based on them
being interested in that.
- What's the subject about?
- So the book that I'm
writing is about my (mumbles)
of becoming a mom and
experiencing miscarriage.
- [Gary] Yep. Great.
So you run, so if you
type in the word miscarriage.
There's a site called
Facebook, at the top it has
a search engine, if
you type in miscarriage,
here's what will happen.
You will see
hundreds of groups on Facebook
and you will see
thousands of pages.
Have you ever run a Facebook ad?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Good.
You go, you make
your piece of content,
it's a picture of you,
it's a picture of the book,
it's a five second video of you,
it's a five minute video of you.
It's a clip from this talk,
I don't care what you do, right?
You place that ad, and
then you target the people
in those groups
and in that interest.
- [Woman 3] Using
detailed targeting?
The end.
You know the answer.
Like that's the answer.
Niches are better.
It's better to sell
Pinot Noir from Burgundy
than it is to sell wine.
It's more narrow
and it's easier to get
to the actual person
and it's cheaper, at times,
depending on the category.
And so, that's what I would do.
You can go to Instagram
and type in miscarriage,
the hashtag, let me
promise you there will be
hundreds of
thousands if not millions.
And then you click the
people that posted about it
and people are talking about it
and then you find somebody
who's equally talking about it,
she has a radio show
on a podcast about it
and then you DM her and say
I'm writing a book about this,
you're talking about this,
I want exposure for my book,
what do you want
from me, and she's like,
I'm just looking for guests.
And now you're done.
(audience applause)
You know what mean?
Those are details.
The thing that makes
what I do hard is it takes
a lot of time, like
I scale unscalable behavior.
It's why Corporate America
has been so weird with me.
Johnson &amp; Johnson's
and you know, and Dove,
and Pepsi and Mountain Dew,
these companies struggle
with the unscalable
nature of my beliefs
because they
believe in width not depth.
It's how they bought
media their whole lives.
It doesn't change the
fact that it's working.
And it doesn't change the fact
that width is not
working anymore because
we don't three television
channels that 50%
of the country
watches the commercials
'cause we didn't
have remote controls.
The world's changed.
And by the way, digitally too.
I'm sorry that banner
ads don't work anymore.
I'm sorry that
affiliate marketing doesn't work
as well on mobile as it did
on desktop, I'm sorry.
But it's the market.
Like Twitter built me,
it doesn't work anymore.
I'm not sitting
in my room crying
that Twitter died. I don't
give shit that blue bird.
(audience laughter)
Sorry that
you blew up on Snapchat
but now it's
declined a little bit, sorry.
Like, you know, you
can't control the market
and where the attention is
but those are details for you.
You got it, hey man.
- (inaudible)
Salt Lake City, Utah.
First of can I say how thankful
I am for your perspective
on life has literally how
changed how I view gratitude
and perspective
on how to live it (inaudible).
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Just want to publicly say
thank you for everything.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- My question is
is there a difference
between asking for
permission from other people
and taking criticism
from your inner circle
and applying it to
how you deploy in a space?
- Of course,
everything's a fine line, right?
That was a really
awesome question, I appreciate
you asking that and
that hasn't been asked of me
in that form.
Of course.
You know how
I always say I don't give
a rat's ass about what
any of, I just said it,
20 minutes ago, I don't give
a shit about what you guys
think about me. I genuinely
care what everyone of you
think about me,
that contradiction,
that tightrope,
that's where all the magic is.
Like it's all,
everybody's trying to figure out
what that kind of
finely formulate it like this
macro patience, micro speed?
Right, 'cause I'm
talking about go fast
and then I'm like patience,
everyone's like what
do you mean, GaryVee?
Like, you listen to me
carefully, I'm confusing
because I'm talking out
of both sides of my mouth
on every issue 'cause
that's actually what it is.
It's like a bridge.
You have to be basically
pulling from both ends.
And so of course,
you know of course,
there's a fine line
between being caught up
in everybody's feedback
stopping you doing anything
and taking the
feedback and applying it.
It's a very fine line.
- Thanks so much.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- Thank you so much.
I love you!
(audience cheers and applause)
- [Gary] Thank you guys.
(light music)